(uplifting accordion tune)
- We are a circus of big family tradition
and the way we present
our show is the same way
that my family presented
the show over 175 years ago.
There's nothing fancy
about what we do here.
It's magic, real magic.
(uplifting accordion tune)
When you grow up in a circus as a child,
you just step into being a clown.
(speaks in Italian)
Welcome to the Zoppé Circus,
thank you for coming!
We're a classic family circus,
which means our family's here
working together, performing together.
Would you like to meet some of our family?
- [Audience] Yeah!
- First of all, there's my mother,
the Matriarch of our family.
Then I have my sister, Carla,
who with her husband, Rudy,
they perform with their dog act.
And then we have my sister, Tosca, she
has the horses on the show.
but she also directs the show.
Her husband, Jay, is an
amazing White Clown.
The White Clown is the straight clown,
he's the best White Clown
that I've ever seen.
The act that my son and I
do right now on the show
is actually a balloon routine.
It's nothing new, I mean
it's thousands of years old,
clowns have been doing it forever.
It happens to be really
cute when he does it,
because he's a adorable;
it's an unexplainable thing
to see my child do what he loves to do.
I mean, I get this seven-year-old,
beautiful little boy
and his heart opens up and
he gives it to everybody.
It's different here, I
think than most places,
when we come into this
ring, we become family.
I believe circus and family
are basically the same world.